PROFESSOR: In this segment,
we will discuss a little bit
the union bound and then discuss
a counterpart, which is known
as the Bonferroni inequality.
Let us start with a story.
Suppose that we have a number
of students in some class.
And we have a set of
students that are smart,
let's call that set a1.
So this is the set
of smart students.
And we have a set of
students that are beautiful.
And let's call that set a2.
So a2 is the set of
beautiful students.
If I tell you that the set
of smart students is small,
and the set of beautiful
students are small,
then you can probably
conclude that there
are very few students that
are either smart or beautiful.
What does this have to
do with probability?
Well, when we say
very few are smart,
we might mean that if I
pick a student at random,
there is only a
small probability
that I pick a smart
student, and similarly
for beautiful students.
Can we make this
statement more precise?
Indeed we can.
We have the union
bound that tells us
that the probability that
I pick a student that
is either smart or
beautiful is less than
or equal to the
probability of being
a smart student plus the
probability of picking
a beautiful student.
So, if this probability is
small and that probability is 1,
then this probability
will also be small,
which means that there is only
a small number of students that
are either smart or beautiful.
Now let us try to turn the
statement around its head.
Suppose that most of
the students are smart
and most of the
students are beautiful.
So in this case, I'm
telling you that these
sets a1 and a2 are big.
Now, if the set
a1 is big, then it
means that this set here,
the complement of a1,
is a small set.
And if I tell you that
the set a2 is big,
then it means that
this set here,
which is a complement
of a2, is also small.
So everything outside
here is a small set, which
means that whatever
is left, which
is the intersection of a1
and a2, should be a big set.
So we should be able to
conclude that, in this case,
most of the students
belong to the intersection.
So they're both
smart and beautiful.
How can we turn this into
a mathematical statement?
It's the following inequality
that we will prove shortly.
But what it says is that the
probability of the intersection
is larger than or
equal to something.
And if this probability
is close to 1,
which says that most of
the students are smart,
and this probability
is close to 1, which
says that more
students are beautiful,
then this difference
here is going
to be close to 1 plus
1 minus 1, which is 1.
Therefore, the probability
of the intersection
is going to be larger than or
equal to some number that's
close to 1.
So this one will also be close
to 1, which is the conclusion
that indeed most students
fall in this intersection
and they're both
smart and beautiful.
So what we will do next will
be to derive this inequality
and actually generalize it.
So here is the relation
that we wish to establish.
We want to show that the
probability of a certain event
is bigger than something.
How do we show that?
One way is to show that the
probability of the complement
of this event, namely
this event here,
we want to show that this
event has small probability.
Now what is this event?
Here we can use
DeMorgan's laws, which
tell us that this event
is the same as this one.
That is, the complement
of an intersection
is the union of the complements.
Since these two sets or
events are identical,
it means that their
probabilities will also
be equal.
And next we will
use the union bound
to write this probability
as being less than
or equal to the sum of the
probabilities of the two events
whose union we are taking.
Now we're getting close,
except that here we
have complements all
over, whereas up here we
do not have any complements.
What can we do?
Well, the probability of
a complement of an event
is the same as 1 minus the
probability of that event.
And we do the same thing for
the terms that we have here.
This probability
here is equal to 1
minus the probability of a1.
And this probability
here is equal to 1
minus the probability of a2.
And now if we take
this inequality,
cancel this term with that term,
and then moved terms around,
what we have is
exactly this relation
that we wanted to prove.
It turns out that
this inequality
has a generalization to
the case where we take
the intersection of n events.
And this has, again, the
same intuitive content.
Suppose that each one of
these events a1 up to a(n)
is almost certain to occur.
That is, it has a
probability close to 1.
In that case, this term
will be close to n.
We subtract n minus 1, so this
term on the right hand side
will be close to 1.
Therefore, the probability
of the intersection
will be larger than or equal
to something that's close to 1.
So this is big.
Essentially what it's saying
is that we have big sets
and we take their
intersection, then
that intersection will
also be big in terms
of having large probability.
How do we prove this relation?
Exactly the same
way as it was proved
for the case of two sets.
Namely, instead of
looking at this event,
we look at the
complement of this event.
And we use DeMorgan's laws
to write this complement
as the union of the complements.
These two are the
same sets or events,
so they have the
same probability.
And then we use the
union bound to write this
as being less than or equal
to the probabilities of all
of those sets.
Now this is equal to 1
minus the probability
of the intersection.
This side here is equal to 1
minus the probability of a1.
This is one term.
We get n such
terms, the last one
being 1 minus the
probability of a(n).
And we still have an
inequality going this way.
We collect those 1s
that we have here.
There's n of them,
and one here, so we're
left with n minus 1 terms
that are equal to 1.
And this gives
rise to this term.
We have all the probabilities
of the various events
that appear with the same sign.
This gives rise to this term.
And finally, this term here
will correspond to that term.
Namely, if we started
with this inequality
and just rearrange
a few terms, we
obtain this inequality up here.
So these Bonferroni inequalities
are a nice illustration
of how one can combine
DeMorgan's laws, set
theoretical operations,
and the union bound
in order to obtain some
interesting relations
between probabilities.